un petit comté rural du sud est de
l'ontario à l'avant garde dans la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
il y a 6 ans oxford quand y est devenue
la première municipalité ontarienne à se
fixer l'objectif d'être carboneutre
d'ici 2050
l'a8 martin siéger au conseil municipal
du comté lorsque la résolution a été
adoptée à l'unanimité de winx club de
cenon et oiseaux j'étais sceptique
confie l'élu mais comme beaucoup il a
été convaincu par les effets de plus en
plus tangible de la crise climatique
pour atteindre sa cible de
carboneutralité hawks fed aura du pain
sur la planche et devra rendre ses
infrastructures plus verte
cette résidence pour aînés qui comble 16
% de ses besoins énergétiques grâce à
des panneaux solaires
17 bâtiments municipaux sont déjà dotées
de cet équipement passer au solaire ne
sera toutefois pas suffisant pour
atteindre la carboneutralité oxu devrait
aussi adapter son parc de véhicules
en 2010 est le comté a été le premier au
pays à se doter d'ambulances hybride un
type de véhicule qui n'existait pas sur
le marché canadien auparavant depuis
décembre blanc sur cèze font appel à ces
technologies
les ambulanciers sont ravis de leur
nouveau véhicule et d'autres villes
veulent suivre l'exemple d'oxford comme
toronto qui se dotera bientôt d'une
centaine d'ambulances hybride de
cet expert basé à montréal salue ses
efforts mais souligne que les défis
opérationnels seront grands eq les
résidents devront aussi changer leurs
habitudes de vie c'est techniquement
possible de l'un dire que c'est réaliste
ça c'est plus difficile parce que
socialement la population je ne crois
pas qu'aujourd'hui elle a conscience des
efforts qui seraient nécessaires pour
passer à une société 100 % renouvelable
s'il est vrai que les cibles de
carboneutralité d'oxfam ne comprennent
pas les émissions des particuliers et
des entreprises
certains mettent quand même la main à la
pâte
les greens rhône exploite cette ferme
depuis des générations en 2013 leur
ferme et fière a amorcé son virage vert
et a commencé à produire du biogaz en
utilisant du purin et d'autres matières
organiques
au départ les greens ronde chercher des
façons de diversifier leurs revenus ils
produisent maintenant assez
d'électricité pour approvisionner
l'équivalent de 400 maisons mais
l'opération n'est pas simple
pour vendre leur électricité les
fermiers doivent eux mêmes se raccorder
aux lignes de courant un investissement
de plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
dollars
l'agriculteur se demande quel serait le
coût pour le consommateur car le passage
au vert d'oxfam ne se fait pas sans
frais une ambulance hybride coûte
jusqu'à 30000 dollars de plus qu'un
modèle diesel et les panneaux solaires
qui alimentent cette résidence pour
aînés ont coûté un demi million de
dollars de dépenses que le comté a fait
sans subvention de la province ou du
fédéral au québec
depuis 30 ans l'amateur de plein air
croit aussi que la province et le
fédéral prenne trop de temps à agir s'il
est conscient que son compte et ne
représente qu'une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan des émissions canadiennes il
veut rester optimiste
il ya le sport quand il ya du monde qui
espèrent
comme lui plusieurs résidants d'oxford
veulent voir leur compte et être un
exemple pour d'autres municipalités
canadiennes et espère qu'avec l'urgence
climatique de plus en plus reconnue le
vent tournera en leur faveur ici est le
média radio canada oxford